[Music]
when it comes to grilled cheese do you
believe less is more or more is more hi
i am nemo i'm a culinary producer at
tasty today i'm going to test recipes
for a 3 6 and 12 ingredient grilled
cheese may the best grilled cheese win
first up we're making our three
ingredient grilled cheese for the first
ingredient we are going to start with
bread
i decide to go with brioche because it's
buttery and fluffy with a hint of
sweetness our next ingredient is butter
everything is better with butter and
since we only can use three ingredients
we want to make them count we are going
to generously butter one side of the
bread and place it on a hot skillet and
for our third and final ingredient we
are adding sliced american cheese and we
have picked american cheese because it's
such a classic top the bread with three
slices of american cheese place the
other slice of bread on top butter side
up when the bottom slice of bread is
golden brown flip and continue cooking
until the other side has browned and the
cheese is fully melted and there we have
it our classic three ingredient grilled
cheese bread butter cheese that really
might be all you need i guess we will
have to wait and see next up we have our
six ingredient grilled cheese our first
two ingredients are the same as our last
version and those are bread and butter
for this version we chose sourdough
bread because we are looking for bread
that's hearty with a little bit of a
tang after we spread the butter on one
side of each slice of bread we are going
to place them butter side down and now
it's time to introduce our new
ingredients ingredient number three is
grated garlic i mean think about it this
is basically becoming a garlic bread
grilled cheese which sounds like a dream
come true ingredient number four is
pesto we tried many different options
for seasonings and condiments but what
we realized is that pesto is the best
way to bring the flavor home
now it's time for cheese we are going to
pick two different types of cheese
mozzarella and sharp provolone we're
using two types of cheese because
mozzarella is creamy while sharp
provolone will give our sandwich a nutty
flavor and you're probably noticing that
these steps are in a bit of a different
order than last time for the three
ingredient grilled cheese we just built
the sandwich right onto the skillet but
because we have more ingredients this
time around we are building our entire
sandwich first to ensure even cooking
throughout
after cooking for about five minutes on
each side our sandwich is a beautiful
golden brown and our cheese is nice
melted time to eat look at that ooey
gooey goodness let's get started on the
12 ingredient grilled cheese our first
ingredient is of course butter we're
going to melt one tablespoon of butter
in a small skillet then add in a quarter
cup of sliced yellow onions and a pinch
of salt yep i said onions make sure to
stir your onions often until they are
soft and starting to caramelize
caramelizing onions usually takes up to
40 minutes but since we're using a very
small quantity we're cutting ours back
to 10 minutes next add in a generous
amount of brown sugar and continue
cooking the onions until the sugar
starts to caramelize add balsamic glaze
and stir
by cooking these beautiful caramelized
onions we will add in some sweetness to
our final dish next up ingredient number
six thyme in a small pot combine the
rest of your butter and the thyme to
create a delicious infused butter this
simple hack is going to be a game
changer we're going to brush our infused
butter into ingredient number seven
our bread for this recipe we went with
artisanal country bread with a thick
crust and a coarse texture this thyme
infused butter will take our bread to
the next level that is why we're
brushing a generous amount on both sides
now it's time to fry everyone has their
own grilled cheese preference but i
think we can all agree that we want the
bread to be golden brown and crispy now
we're going to start assembly this is
definitely way more work than the
average grilled cheese but trust us the
outcome will totally be worth it
ingredient number eight coarse ground
dijon mustard spread the mustard evenly
on both slices of bread next up aged
cheddar we're going to add the shredded
cheese next ham this is not just a ham
and cheese sandwich this is an upgraded
grilled cheese our next cheese is
gruyere gruyere is rich creamy and salty
while the aged cheddar is sharp on our
other slice of bread add the caramelized
onions sandwich it up before we throw
this back on the heat let's sprinkle the
pan with our 12th and final ingredient
parmesan cheese
we will then carefully place our
sandwich on top of the parmesan cheese
while the parmesan cheese melts and
crisps up to create a crust we're going
to top the other side of our sandwich
with the rest of the parmesan this is my
favorite hack to get our bread nice and
crispy which will really make a
difference in the final sandwich since
both slices of bread are a beautiful
color and our cheese is melted it's time
to plate here we have it our 12
ingredient grilled cheese not only do we
have a creamy cheesy interior but we
have a crispy parmesan crust sweet
caramelized onions and a kick from the
mustard and there we have it our three
ingredient six ingredient and 12
ingredient grilled cheese when picking
my favorite sandwich between the three i
had to consider flavor texture and which
sandwich i would want to eat again i
love how easy and classic the three
ingredient grilled cheese is and the
pesto and cheese combo in the sixth
ingredient grilled cheese tasted so
great but at the end of the day i keep
going back for more bites of the 12
ingredient grilled cheese thanks for
joining me as i test our favorite three
grilled cheese sandwiches let us know
how you make your favorite grilled
cheese at home bye
[Music]
you